[Music]
Kourtney Kardashian has had it with
Scott Disick given up on being with the
person that I have to reach into in a
sneak peak from the next episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians the 38
year old reality star tells her mom Kris
Jenner
she is pretty fed up with her act he
needs to get a life leave me alone
the topic comes up while the
mother-daughter duo discussed their
recent trip port just got back from
celebrating her birthday in Mexico with
some of her girls it was really really
the best four days of my life while Kris
spent a day camping with Scott and the
kiddos I think the kids had fun
how was Scott I think he was jealous
because we were having fun spending time
with other people oh that's a really not
fair it's just like I can't even live my
life Kourt argues that Scott tries to
make everyone feel bad for him but Kris
isn't buying it
wouldn't you be sad if he truly left you
alone you always want what you can't
have and when somebody's right they're
giving you their heart he's not though
if he was that was one thing he's not
the story that's what he makes it seem
he sits there and gravels and feels bad
for himself so if that's was his truth
why can't he get it together
[Music]